Justin Bieber became the new underwear
model for Calvin Klein and there he is
right there yeah
who everyone says unfortunately right
after the ads came out people began
saying the picture had been photoshopped
in Justin Bieber is not that muscular or
that well-endowed someone even put out a
gif showing what they claimed was before
and after photoshopped this was
everywhere all over the internet over
the weekend there's saying that there's
the before and there's the after and you
see he's been enhanced down below and up
top yeah it looks like his his skull
grows too and yeah before that's
basically what that's like a sign
outside a weird bar
Mary can do now I'm going in there for
drink anyway Bieber's camp denies this
and frankly I'm on Bieber's side you see
a few years back I did an underwear ad
myself can I just point out and this is
the truth it before everyone dutifully
when a woman audibly went I don't know
who it was
who's the most honest thing I've heard
no I know who you are but I love you
fear honesty anyway I'm on Bieber's side
cuz a few years back I did an underwear
ad and everyone said mine had been
photoshopped to make me look bigger
check it out and I think it's terrible
[Applause]
I live for the sake of that joke we got
a woman from the waist down
right right I've got a real Barbie groin
in that photo mark they old Barbie groin
that's not a saying last night
you